bonsoir voici les titres de ce journal
le ministre de l'intérieur jean pierre
chevènement se trouve dans le coma
depuis plus de 24 heures mais son état
s'améliore lentement vient d'annoncer le
l'hôpital du val de grâce
un avion de la swiss air s'est abîmé
dans l'océan atlantique
nous allons le voir après ces images de
l'hôpital du val de grâce où se trouve
actuellement monsieur jean pierre
chevènement et puis je voulais vous
annoncer ce deuxième type puisqu'un
avion la suisse hier s'est abîmé dans
l'océan atlantique au large de la
province canadienne de nouvelle écosse
il y avait 2 129 personnes à bord il n'y
a pas de survivant un pic troisième site
ce sera la rentrée scolaire pour les
petits et les grands ne le verrons dans
quelques instants
l'état de santé de monsieur chevènement
s'améliore lentement ce sont les termes
très récent d'un communiqué diffusé peu
après 22h15 par le médecin chef de
l'hôpital d'instruction des armées du
val-de-grâce à paris le ministre de
l'intérieur se trouve dans le coma
depuis plus de 24 heures victime d'un
arrêt cardiaque
le ministre avait été admis au val de
grâce pour y subir l'ablation de calcul
dans la vésicule biliaire monsieur
chevènement a fait une allergie au
produit anesthésiant contenant du curare
son coeur s'est arrêté n'est pas reparti
spontanément mais à l'issue de plusieurs
dizaines de minutes de massage tout au
long de cette journée des nouvelles à la
fois alarmiste et rassurantes se sont
succédé benoît duquesne vous êtes au val
de grâce ce soir on est toujours prudent
mais plutôt un petit peu optimiste
oui vous venez de le dire c'est vrai que
les médecins sont très très prudent
encore il dit simplement que ils se
sentent modérément raisonnablement
optimiste par rapport à 7 cm état de
santé de monsieur chevènement dont vous
venez de le dire
il s'améliore lentement c'est le texte
du communiqué officiel publié ci au val
de grâce peut dire que toute la journée
on a donc attendu que ce soit à matignon
au ministère de l'intérieur et bien sûr
ici au val-de-grâce attendu des
nouvelles de cet état de santé il y a eu
l'épousé de monsieur chevènement qui est
venu lui rendre visite accompagnée de
l'un de ses fils il y a eu monsieur
georges sarre le président délégué du
mouvement des citoyens
et puis pour le gouvernement s'était
charge jocelyn le ministre délégué à la
coopération qui s'est rendu dans la
chambre de ce service de soins intensifs
où il se trouve toujours
et puis en fin d'après midi on a vu
venir ici le médecin chef de l'hôpital
le médecin général yves cudennec est
venu donc confirmer avec cette présence
vous avez dû entendre les termes de
l'amélioration de santé de monsieur
chevènement
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur a
été hospitalisé à l'hôpital
d'instruction des armées du val-de-grâce
pour y subir une intervention
chirurgicale programmée sur la digue
biliaire il a été victime au tout début
de l'année saisie d'un arrêt cardiaque
très probablement d'origine profite à la
fidak tic les mesures de réanimation
adéquates ont été prises immédiatement
il est actuellement placé en service de
soins intensifs et son état s'améliore
lentement un nouveau communiqué sera
diffusé dans 24 heures
il est réactif mais la famille de
monsieur chevénement a souhaité que je
n'en dise pas plus dont vous comprendrez
que je respecte son but mais les choses
s'améliorent lentement mais sûrement
nous sommes très modérément optimiste
pour l'instant y'a pas de pronostics sur
l'accident l'accident est beaucoup trop
récent pour qu'on puisse porter un
pronostic aujourd'hui faut se donner un
peu de temps vous constatez cette
prudence il est réactif ça veut dire
tout simplement de la passion n'a plus à
voir par ailleurs et bien que par
exemple et ça c'est de très bon augure
monsieur chevènement réagi à l'énoncé de
son nom qu'il a bouger les paupières
qu'il a réagi aussi en bougeant les
doigts autrement dit il est en phase
ascendante de sortie du coma mais il s'y
trouve toujours
ce qui veut dire que par exemple le
ministère de l'intérieur dans son
entourage proche on se montre là aussi
très prudent on constate effectivement
cette amélioration et on s'en réjouit
bien sûr après les nouvelles très très
alarmante qu'on a eu toute la journée et
aussi les détails qui sont venus
s'ajouter sur cette réalité
cette animation très lourde qu'il a dû
subir tout cela donc on enregistre mais
on attend bien sûr d'en savoir plus si
vos oreilles